ilan est inclus il a fait 544 laisse moi
juste pour le clip en faire une au moins
je vais dire que je tapais de pour tout
le monde on va accueillir une légende
qui est prête il nous vivions avec sa
fille on est très aimé tous comme dit
oui parce que c'est une des plus grandes
stars du sport voilà vraiment c'est une
légende de tous les lobbys des mecs
comme ça il y en a cinq
yahia federer il ya michael jordan ya
tyson et voilà il ya ainsi commissaire
yamissi à nadal
et bien il est avec nous ce soir il y
avait que sa fille millan mike tyson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que
[Applaudissements]
raisani
quel âge as-tu millan tata disant je
crois n'a rien non plus regardez
regardez jamais l anneau vont regarder
comment ils jouent c'est un truc de ouf
c'est mike qu'il entraîne elle est fan
de tennis tu met une énorme championne
et might je suis très heureux de te voir
tu joue au tennis tu joues du plat et
nsue accuse ainsi un peu je t'ai vu le
gtv non non je déconne on va jouer tous
les deux ok tu peux me battre
un bar
[Rires]
allez donc jeter parade va taper fort il
anéantit clou il a fait 544 laisse moi
juste pour le kiff en faire une au moins
que je vais dire que j ai tapé devant
tout le monde
[Rires]
le remake
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup pour tout le monde
cherchait fracassé mal mac tu la coach
je vais jouer contre ta fille y les gars
je vais lancer une balle dans le public
je vous le dis si milla ne bat la
personne ne repartira avec 5000 euros
d'accord similan perd malheureusement ce
sera perdu d'accord on fait ça en cinq
points l'accord mylan et un petit cours
on a installé un petit cours dehors
ok on joue trois contre moi et c'est ton
papa qui va coacher hockey mike tu la
coach entre moi tu sais que j'étais
champion de tunisie - novate si je gagne
c'est toute ta vie
dès que tu feras nine et dès que tu
seras quelque part tu diras je suis fort
mais le plus fort ça reste quand même
baba oui c'est ça un vrai t'as peur
c'est fait merci tu sais faire et
l'anonymat en trois points fait pote
hockey fait pas de servir est à ta pas
trop faim c'est bon monsieur rim mike tu
veux lui dire un truc
natoora pas trop fort parce qu on fera
quoi fort
fais gaffe dehors c'est une bagnole
c'est plus tard al elam appel mais
là-bas la sauvette j'apparais musical et
hypotonique bon aura 10 à 0 pour toi
allez c'est parti
non c'est faute à sylla a partout mais
aussi j'ai moi aussi moi aussi j'ai des
enfants des garçons de jouer à trois
points les en trois poules ok les belges
actuels et balle de match
[Applaudissements]
tu te fous toi j'adore avons vu
l'adversaire
le vrai quoi my je veux jouer avec elle
à moins que tu plais oui weaver d'accord
à roland garros je vais jouer avec elle
et là je peux te dire tu vas voir tu
veux montrer la vidéo parce que là elle
m'a elle m'a énervé qui peut battre la
famille tyson et ben on a vu que ils
sont très forts
[Musique]